there are 24 hours in a day but no
matter what
we never feel like it's enough time to
get anything done
a lot of us feel that way we feel
pressure to never be late or
when we do oh god it's like unforgivable
and it's something we struggle with
so i want to break the cycle of bad time
management
to give us all a feel of control in our
day but first let's take a look at
helen's story
i just woke up but somehow i already
feel like i'm running
late i need to get the kids ready for
school
i need to get myself ready for work so
here goes another fun busy day
i came upstairs to
get my makeup done for work
and i realized that my makeup
is at my office because yesterday i
had to run out so fast that i didn't
have time to do it
the kids are all set for school they've
ate their lunch is ready
and i'm out
i need to like be on another call in
about
10 minutes realize that i didn't bring
any snacks with me today
but i usually order something to the
office and eat at my desk anyhow
today i'm lucky because i have uh
my coffee still from this morning and uh
that's gonna be my lunch for the day
i thought i would get to come home today
by about 5 5 30 but i was running a
little late
i'm going to start making dinner and
then i'm going to spend some time with
the kids
and i will get back to work
i've been sitting here um working
for the last hour and a half now i'm
looking around
and the whole house is a complete mess
so
i'm gonna go do the dishes and get
cleaned up and then we do it all
over again it seems like
so much got done and nothing got done
helen i can't even look at you all right
i'm gonna face you now
and the reason why is because i cried
when i watched your video
um yeah i so
relate to so many things you said
do you feel like an overall
weight in your life about time
management
you know i i run my own law practice
and i have two kids in elementary school
and i'm on the pta
and i'm class mom and there's always no
time
there's never time i mean it's just it's
always stressful the pressure is on me
to get everything
done and yeah there's always a weight
that hangs over you that
did i get this done did i did i get this
for my son did i did i do this for the
school did i do this for work there's
always that weight
well see when i'm talking to you i can
see you so objectively i'm like listen
maybe you don't need to be on the pta
maybe you're just a working mom
and that's already infinite boxes to
check
and maybe there's stuff that can come
off the table when i say that
how does what what goes on in your head
i want to do everything
okay you know it's almost like i'm a
glutton for punishment
okay so how do you break the cycle
of feeling overwhelmed and daunted by
everything you have to do and start
forgiving yourself
i don't know i i just
the things i do i want to do i like love
my job and i love my kids and i love
being there for them and being active
so how do i break the cycle that's one
of my biggest struggles
because when i watch your video i do
sense a weight like
it's not like you're not light as a
feather about it you're like
this is heavy stuff that i'm grappling
with and if you're
piling it all on the plate then
you either have to take some stuff off
the plate or start feeling
fortified about all your choices and i
want to
tell you like lighten up like feel good
about it you're being
amazing look at all that you're doing
like screw it you should be patting
yourself on the back
yeah some days you do and then most days
you're
just making it through so
how do you break the cycle you know
i don't know you know i i feel like
maybe it is
lightening up the load a little bit but
you know i think that the cycle keeps
going if you want to do all those things
i want to do it all too i really do like
at no point in my life i started working
when i was in diapers
so you know i hope at some point i am in
diapers
still working um
yes that's right uh i started there i
plan to
end there and yet i
haven't changed certain behaviors in my
life
that might lead to better time
management right
and when i say lighten up i mean if
you're going to make all these choices
then just be lighter about it
leave the plate heavy right do you think
you can do that
yeah i mean i try to lighten up but some
days you're just
you just can't like at the end of the
day you're like
i need to do this i need to do that what
did i accomplish you feel pulled down
by all the choices you made and boxes
you have to check
right so do you think your
time management issue is more about
making peace with all that you've put on
your plate rather than being on time to
every appointment
um yeah possibly i'm hard on myself i
feel like i look back and i say i want
to be the best at my job i want to be
the best mom i want to be the best wife
i mean you not like you want to be the
best in everything you do and
it's it's hard to be the best in
everything something takes a toll
eventually
where does best measure up to you where
does the source of what's best
um i just i i guess it's probably
just the way i was raised i think that
my parents
i'm first generation american my parents
came from russia and they had to
work work work work work you know to
always
do their best and the best was always
expected of me
you know because they didn't come here
for nothing as my dad would say
so i always had to do do do and i guess
that transfers over into now
trying to be the best in everything
so i see a pattern like i see
a burning fire and mine is because my
parents were the exact opposite
like they you know they were so bohemian
that it turned me into the other
direction like it lit some type of fire
of
accountability and work as my parent and
something that was
incredibly structured right i definitely
need to know
how to not be five minutes late
every time but i want to be five minutes
early
and like be able to waste time and
luxuriate in time
i totally feel you the struggle and the
struggle is real
with the time with the clock i'm always
what time is it what time is it my
six-year-old gets annoyed with me
i feel like i'm not usually happy with
the result too like
it's usually my reaction to time is like
ah
it's what it's never like oh cool
it's that gotcha i'm literally like
right
i'm screwing up again is what time it is